[Música]
cuántas veces nos hemos tenido que
enfrentar para resolver un problema que
parece prácticamente imposible
y que luego encontramos que la solución
era sumamente sencilla
hoy quiero compartir con todos ustedes
algunas anécdotas en las cuales un mismo
problema se resolvió de dos formas
diferentes
una forma laboriosa complicada y costosa
y otra forma mucho más simple
con esto quiero decirles que
generalmente la solución a los problemas
más complejos radica en lo básico y lo
fundamental
cuando la nasa inició con el envío de
los astronautas al espacio se
encontraron con el problema de que los
bolígrafos no funcionaban a gravedad
cero
resolver este problema le tomó a la nasa
6 años y 12 millones de dólares de
inversión
desarrollaron un bolígrafo que
prácticamente escribía en cualquier
ambiente agrave de acero bajo el agua al
revés en cualquier superficie
a menos 0 grados centígrados y a más de
300 grados centígrados sin duda un gran
aporte para la ciencia
sin embargo como lo hicieron los rusos
que en ese mismo época competían por la
conquista
del espacio los rusos
utilizaron un lápiz
y aquí
lo importante de conocer la diferencia
en cómo resolver un problema de forma
eficiente o de forma eficaz
tanto la nasa como los rusos resolvieron
el problema
pero el gran problema que se le presentó
a la nasa los rusos lo resolvieron de
una forma muy eficiente y muy eficaz
por ejemplo si tuviéramos que matar una
mosca podríamos hacerlo de dos formas
utilizando
combate moscas o utilizando una granada
si utilizamos un matamoscas lo haríamos
de forma eficiente
si utilizamos una granada lo haríamos de
forma muy eficaz pero es importante
conocer la diferencia entre eficiencia
eficacia eficacia es alcanzar nuestros
objetivos sin necesariamente utilizar
nuestros recursos de la forma más óptima
y eficiencia es alcanzar nuestros
objetivos pero sigue utilizando los
recursos de la forma más óptima
con esto quiero decirles que cuando sean
gerentes sean líderes de alguna
organización
tenga presente que tendrán que
administrar sus recursos de la forma más
eficiente
para todos aquellos emprendedores que
piensen con iniciar un negocio tengan
presente que montar un negocio entre
otras garantías de esa era tener que
resolver problemas a diario a diario
ser gerente ser líder es ser un
solucionador de problemas
deben de convertirse en maestros en la
búsqueda de las soluciones más simples
estoy plenamente seguro que muchos de
ustedes
ocuparán muy pronto cargos importantes
en el desempeño de su profesión y de su
vida cotidiana
pero tengan presente que tendrán que
presentar y resolver problemas de todo
tipo y toda dificultad
algunas veces más algunas veces menos
sin embargo lo fundamental radica
encontrar la solución más adecuada
tienen que saber a qué se enfrentan
tienen que conocer el problema
en la organización que dirijo nos hemos
podido desarrollar en tres importantes
áreas la infraestructura vial
la inmobiliaria y las energías
renovables y en cada una de ellas para
poderlas desarrollar
hemos tenido que convertirnos en
expertos del conocimiento del detalle y
lo básico
por eso es que siempre le digo a mi
equipo de trabajo
que por simple o difícil que sea la
actividad que vayamos a desarrollar
tenemos que al menos conocer el detalle
de lo básico
por eso les digo si vamos a diseñar o
construir una piscina tendremos que
convertirnos en piscinas
si vamos a tener que diseñar o construir
una ventana vamos a tener que
convertirnos en venta de venta los logos
en fin tenemos que convertirnos expertos
en lo que hacemos porque sólo conociendo
el detalle lo que realizamos podemos
encontrar la correcta solución a los
problemas
también quiero compartir con ustedes que
además de
además de la importancia
de buscar siempre las soluciones más
simples es sumamente importante poder y
saber escuchar por eso quiero referirme
a una anécdota que sucedió en japón en
una fábrica
que producía artículos de limpieza
esta fábrica fue demandada por un
consumidor porque resulta que luego de
haber comprado varias cajas de jabón se
encontró con que muchas de ellas venían
vacías
de inmediato los gerentes de la fábrica
llamaron a todos sus ingenieros y les
pidieron que por favor se abocarán a
buscar una solución para que eso no
volviera a suceder trabajaron muy duro y
pudieron diseñar una máquina de rayos-x
en la cual
con monitores de alta resolución y
manejado por dos personas lo apuntan
hacia la línea de producción y cada vez
que pasaba una caja vacía era fácilmente
detectada
sin embargo este mismo problema se le
planteó a un empleado de una pequeña
empresa
y este empleado en lugar de empezar con
complicadas soluciones de rayos-x e
ingeniería electrónica
lo hizo de otra forma diferente
se compró un abanico industrial lo puso
sobre la línea de producción lo encendió
y cada vez que pasaba una caja vacía
ésta salía volando
con eso
con esto quiero decirles
que realmente los dos casos resolvieron
el problema
pero solamente uno lo hizo de forma
eficiente
recordemos
a siempre que las soluciones más simples
son tan obvias que muchos las dejamos
pasar
pues estamos más abocados al problema
que a la solución
tenemos que ver lo básico
tenemos que utilizar el sentido común
por eso mi consejo para todos ustedes
que empiezan
no compliquen su trabajo busque la
solución más simple centres en las
soluciones y no en los problemas
escuchen a los colaboradores
y manejen los recursos de la forma más
eficiente muchas gracias
[Aplausos]